now to louisiana which is struggling to
recover after hurricane delta barreled
through the state over the weekend the
state saw heavy flooding on roadways and
in neighborhoods
along with high winds and widespread
destruction about
seven weeks after being slammed by
hurricane laura homes were destroyed and
hundreds of thousands are still without
power
our lead national correspondent david
begno is from south louisiana
and he's in lake charles as we speak
david good morning to you
good morning welcome to my beloved home
state look at this this is a vehicle
under the front portion of a home which
collapsed on it the people evacuated
that happened seven weeks ago but they
haven't come back home because there was
just another hurricane that hit
last weekend let me tell you the people
of louisiana we love to cook for you
we love to share what we have and we
love to tell stories
and the stories being told by the people
of southwest louisiana
are that tens of thousands of people are
living under blue tarps they're living
with holes in their roofs and a lot of
people
are living in trailers in the front yard
of their home
from the back of a coast guard
surveillance plane we stood on an
open ramp belted in for our own safety
as the devastation below came into focus
this is creole louisiana on the gulf
coast
where hurricane delta made landfall
friday night with 100 mile per hour
winds
40 miles north of here is the city of
lake charles
southwest louisiana is known for its oil
refineries
but surrounding the refineries as far as
the eye could see
is that sea of blue blue tarps covering
damaged homes
that were hit by laura seven weeks ago
and the delta
friday night that's it the puma yep
we have a front bedroom where my parents
stay and the back has three bunk beds
where me my brother and my sister stay
five people in that one camper and three
dogs wow
this is where the lebov family is now
living braley says her family moved out
of their home after hurricane laura
tore off most of the roof seven weeks
ago
then friday night the blue tarps that
were covering the roof
were ripped off during hurricane delta
which allowed rainwater to pour red
even the building that they got to
temporarily house their belongings after
hurricane
laura was flipped over by delta braley
says her family lost their homes to
hurricanes
when she was five and eight years old
she's now 19.
this is the first time we come back to
something that we can actually fix
exhausted this is tracy joseph she had
no major damage during hurricane laura
seven weeks ago
she took in five family members who were
left homeless by it
then last weekend they all evacuated to
houston for hurricane delta
when they came back they walked into
this half of the ceiling
is gone god bless tracy she's waking up
this morning
just around the corner from where we are
with a big old hole in her roof
there were two storm related deaths
after delta friday night
but do you know that the majority of
hurricane related deaths here in
louisiana over the last seven weeks have
come from carbon monoxide poisoning
so all my friends in louisiana i'm
talking to you if you're using a
generator keep it at least 20 feet away
from you
outside because the carbon monoxide
poisoning is killing people
please beware anthony back to you yeah
very important advice david thank you